Oh
sometimes when I'm in a long plane
flight I gaze out at all those mountains
and deserts and try to get my head round
how vast our earth is and then I
remember there's an object we see every
day that would literally fit 1 million
Earth's inside it the Sun seems
impossibly big but in the great scheme
of things it's a pinprick one of about
400 billion stars in the Milky Way
galaxy which you can see on a clear
night as a pale white mist stretched
across the sky and it gets worse there
are maybe a hundred billion galaxies
detectable by our telescopes so if each
star was the size of a single grain of
sand just the Milky Way has enough stars
to fill a 30-foot by 30-foot stretch of
beach 3 feet deep with sand and the
entire Earth doesn't have enough beaches
to represent the stars in the overall
universe as such a beach would continue
for literally hundreds of millions of
miles holy Stephen Hawking that is a lot
of stars but he and other physicists now
believe in a reality that is
unimaginably bigger still I mean first
of all 100 billion galaxies within range
of our telescopes are probably a
miniscule fraction of the total space
itself is expanding at an accelerating
pace the vast majority of the galaxies
are separating from us so fast that
light from them may never reach us still
our physical reality here on earth is
intimately connected to those distant
invisible galaxies we could think of
them as part of our universe they make
up a single giant edifice obeying the
same physical laws and all made from the
same types of atoms electrons protons
quarks neutrinos that make up you and me
however recent theories in physics
including one called string theory and
now telling us there could be countless
other universes built on different types
of particles with different properties
obeying different laws most of these
universes could ever support life and
might flash in and out of existence in a
nanosecond but nonetheless combined they
make up a vast multiverse of possible
universes and up to 11 dimensions
featuring wonders beyond a while
imagination and the leading version of
string theory predicts a multiverse made
up of 10 to the 500 universes the one
followed by 500 zeros a number so vast
that if every atom in our observable
universe had its own universe and all of
the atoms in all those universes each
had their own universe and you repeated
that for two more cycles you'd still be
at a tiny fraction of the total namely
one trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillionth but even
that number is miniscule compared to
another number infinity some physicists
think the space-time continuum is
literally infinite that it contains an
infinite number of so-called pocket
universes with varying properties as
your brain doing quantum theory adds a
whole new wrinkle I mean the theory has
been proven true beyond all doubt but
interpreting it is baffling and some
physicists think you can only unbeli if
you imagine that huge numbers of
parallel universes are being spawned
every moment and many of these universes
would actually be very like the world
wherein would include multiple copies of
you in one such universe you graduate
with honors and marry the person of your
dreams in another not so much well there
are still some scientists who would say
hogwash the only meaningful answer the
question of how many universes there are
is one only one universe and a few
philosophers and mystics like the hooker
that even our own universe is an
illusion so as you can see right now
there is no agreement on this question
not even close
all we know is the answer is somewhere
between 0 and infinity well I guess we
know one other thing this is a pretty
cool time to be studying physics we just
might be undergoing the biggest paradigm
shift in knowledge that humanity has
ever seen
you